so we unfortunately have to have today
what is a very
a real but admittedly depressing
conversation
and it's really about the future of the
united states be it biden or trump who
wins
in november and i want to approach this
from a slightly different angle so let
me let me sort of set it up for you
the starting point is that in all
likelihood
more than 60 million americans are going
to vote for four more years of donald
trump
in november they're going to see they
will have seen
what we saw for the last three and a
half years and they're going to say
i'm going to vote for four more years of
that and
the important context here is that
certainly
depending on who wins the election
we are changing the direction of the
country in the sense that if donald
trump gets another four years that's one
direction if joe biden replaces donald
trump that's a completely different
direction
but i was having a conversation
yesterday with former producer lewis and
we were talking about sort of the
outlook for the country
and inevitably these discussions come up
about
you know if biden wins then this or if
the senate goes to democrats than that
or if trump then this other path goes
forward
and of course the november election
results are going to have
major consequences we've been looking at
policy differences over the last several
months
and when you look at tax policy
yesterday donald trump during his
press briefings saying that he would
actually be cutting the capital gains
tax whereas joe biden wants to tax
capital gains as ordinary income which
would be i mean these are really
large differences in policy uh look at
um green new deal elements that joe
biden is including in his climate plan
versus what donald trump has done i mean
just look at almost any policy and you
see that these are very different
trajectories but
there's a really big difference in terms
of
outcome versus the makeup of the country
and when it comes to
voting in all likelihood somewhere
between
60 million and 66 million people
are going to vote for donald trump and
maybe the range is a little bigger maybe
it's like at least 58 million and
probably no more than 68 million people
are going to vote for donald trump but
around 60 million people are going to
say
this is the guy i want so the point i'm
making
is that even if we set the country on a
different path in january
by electing joe biden in november if
donald trump
is indeed removed somewhere around half
of the voters
will have voted for donald trump and
this
is not trivial this has real
consequences day to day for you
and for me beyond what the president
does so
certainly if you think about climate
putting in biden instead of trump will
make a massive difference
but depending on where you live half of
the school committee you might be
involved in
will be made up of trump voters
police officers doctors accountants
the people that we are going to be
interacting with
on a daily basis even if joe biden ekes
out a win over donald trump from the
standpoint of the electoral college
these folks aren't going away and their
ideology doesn't get changed or fixed
because their candidate loses the
electoral college
and i don't know what the answer to that
is and we've talked before
in these segments about trumpism doesn't
end
when donald trump leaves office be it in
january or january of 2025.
that's not just a catchphrase it's not
trivial it's not unimportant it's
extraordinary really and how do we start
thinking about that
because it's such a bigger issue and you
know there's this phrase that's often
mentioned it's something like
trump didn't create racists but they're
just more comfortable out in public
right now
much along the same lines donald trump
did not create
anti-intellectualism or
pseudo-intellectualism we've done
interviews and i've explained to you
that those ideologies have been around
since
uh the 1800s in some form approximating
what we have today
and uh they have been coalesced into
um a sort of voting bloc at this point
we saw it with george w
bush and we see it even more with with
donald trump and so this is a bigger
picture issue there's no doubt that
much more than george w bush donald
trump has
sort of coalesced and emboldened this
non-thinking crowd
but once the election's over and
hopefully trump leaves this january
it might not be until january of 2025 it
remains to be seen
what happens with that anti-intellectual
non-thinking trumpist ideology
that doesn't go away what happens in the
senate
what happens in the house of
representatives this is not trivial and
it's something that we really have to
think about and what no matter
who wins the presidency there will be
somewhere around
60 to 65 million people who say
what i saw the last three and a half
years i voted for more of it
hopefully they won't get it but we'll
still have to deal with those people
and that gets me to the next topic i
want to discuss with you today
which actually relates to the popular
vote sort of in this context so let's
talk about that next
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware
of for so long and other things got in
the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video